recuerdo cuando la niña que me pone
hacer este ejercicio nos dice los
pusieron a ustedes también alguna vez
pero el objetivo era encontrar una
figura a partir de unir ciertos puntos
la lógica para unir esos puntos podía
variar a veces pueden ser números primos
el resultado de la multiplicación
números consecutivos o números pares
como en este caso
el primer paso que hacíamos todos y
estoy segura era acercarnos al papel lo
que más podíamos no sé cómo logramos ver
tan cerca del pupitre pero siempre
funcionaba siempre lográbamos encontrar
esa lógica que estaba detrás como unir
esos puntos y arrancamos con el 14 el 16
el 18 y así consecutivamente el problema
estaba que no
solamente nos estamos fijando en cuál
era ese siguiente punto no nos estamos
fijando en la imagen
esto solamente ocurría hasta el final
hasta que nos alejamos de la hoja ay si
veíamos y ahí la magia ocurría
allí encontramos una imagen muy linda
muy clara y nos emocionamos porque hemos
encontrado la ballena el tiburón el
dinosaurio
pero bueno quiero hacer una encuesta
cada entre el público quien alguna vez
obtuvo una imagen como esta
o como esta otra
ajá
muchos de ustedes cierto esto pasado
porque estábamos tan enfocados en ir
punto por punto que no nos dábamos
cuenta cuando habíamos cometido un error
no teníamos claro si la imagen que
estamos construyendo tenía sentido o no
esto sólo ha pasado hasta el final hasta
que ya veíamos la imagen completa y nos
damos cuenta que habíamos cometido un
error que a veces tenía arreglo y a
veces no a veces era tan difícil de
resolver que teníamos que volver a
empezar
algo parecido me pasó cuando trabajé
para el programa de tuberculosis como
consultor
esto en un programa que estaba enmarcado
entre el año un convenio entre el
ministerio de salud y la organización
internacional para las migraciones
y ustedes se preguntarán que hacía una
ingeniera industrial como yo trabajando
en temas de salud pública y tienen toda
la razón en preguntárselo
realmente no era por mi conocimiento
sobre la tuberculosis de hecho para mí
en ese momento estar una enfermedad que
estaba prácticamente radicada en el
mundo que ya en muy pocas ciudades había
casos pero no era así después de leer un
par de artículos descubrí que solamente
en 2016 10.4 millones de personas en el
mundo se enfermaron de tuberculosis y
1.7 murieron por esta causa así que
definitivamente no estaba erradicada
en realidad me contrataron para apoyar
este este convenio principalmente por mi
experiencia en temas de dinámica de
sistemas esta es una herramienta de
pensamiento sistémico que permite ver
los problemas desde otra perspectiva con
otros ojos permite analizar este
problema en un sistema en el que hay
muchas personas con intereses diferentes
que toman decisiones y este sistema
permite y termina generando cosas que a
veces nos gustan y a veces no tanto como
la tuberculosis
pero bueno antes de contarles cuál fue
mi aporte en este proyecto quiero
hablarles un poquito más sobre la
tuberculosis la tuberculosis es una
enfermedad que se transmite por vía
aérea es generada por un bacilo que se
llama 'mycobacterium tuberculosis'
este bacilo se libera cuando una persona
con tuberculosis todo sebo estornuda y
realmente si su familia sus compañeros
de trabajo personas desconocidas que
están alrededor lo inhalan se infectan
algo clave que también es importante
tener en cuenta es que no necesariamente
una persona que se infecta desarrolla la
enfermedad esto depende del sistema
inmunitario que tenga si tiene muy
buenas defensas es posible que su cuerpo
simplemente encapsule este bacilo y
reduzca el riesgo de desarrollar la
enfermedad de un 45 por ciento a un 5
por ciento
pero personas que vienen esta
vulnerabilidad ya sea porque viven en
estados en amiens donde la iluminación y
la ventilación no son adecuadas o que
tienen una condición como vih que
debilita este sistema inmune pues son
mucho más propensas a desarrollar la
enfermedad
por esto es clave iniciar el tratamiento
de forma oportuna
porque de lo contrario una persona puede
incluso morir
y esa es la clave el tratamiento 1
romper ese ciclo de contagio así ya
menos personas se están enfermando por
ende menos personas están teniendo
tuberculosis están expulsando asilos y
el segundo lugar es esto
eliminar
esas muertes por tuberculosis porque si
una persona puede morir por tuberculosis
y no se trata oportunamente y eso no es
justo no es justo que si existen un
tratamiento que pueda curar la
enfermedad sigan muriendo personas
así que teniendo en cuenta esto uno la
importancia del tratamiento oportuno y
dos que la mayor cantidad de personas
con tuberculosis pertenecen a
poblaciones vulnerables el ministerio de
salud decidió dar el tratamiento de
forma gratuita
no saben como yo me emocioné cuando me
enteré de esto realmente el gobierno
estaba destinando muchos recursos a
eliminar una enfermedad que había matado
a personas por siglos
pero bueno esta política se implementó
llegó a las regiones donde había más
carga es decir de una gran más casos de
tuberculosis y pasó el tiempo empezaron
a llegar resultados
estos resultados se analizaron y no
saben lo que descubrimos si la
tuberculosis había disminuido las
muertes por tuberculosis habían
disminuido pero solamente en el año
anterior 10 mil 795 colombianos habían
se habían enfermado de tuberculosis el
40 por ciento tuvo un tratamiento
oportuno y mil 30 murieron por esta
causa
esto me dejó en shock el ministerio está
totalmente sorprendido porque realmente
nadie entendía porque si el tratamiento
se está dando en forma gratuita seguía
habiendo muertes por tuberculosis esto
era algo totalmente contra intuitivo
y querían entenderlo querían resolver
lo que pasó
es muy parecido con una persona tiene
dolor de cabeza entonces si usted siente
olor de cabeza que hacen se toman una
pastilla cierto esa pastilla los alivia
se sienten mejor pueden seguir con su
día al día siguiente vuelven a tener
dolor de cabeza esta persona se toma
otra pastilla se alivia va al trabajo
pasan los días y sigue teniendo dolores
de cabeza ya le parece raro y decidí ir
al médico el médico ya le manda un tag
le manda una resonancia magnética y
descubren que lo que tenía esta persona
en realidad era un tumor
un tumor que tal vez se habría podido
descubrir antes si las pastillas no
hubieran ocultado esos síntomas si las
pastillas de un ocultado el tumor esto
es lo que pasa cuando no hablo no vemos
los problemas de forma sistémica cuando
no vemos ese mapa completo y eso es algo
totalmente natural en nosotros como
seres humanos nuestro cerebro extra está
predeterminado para pensar linealmente
causa-efecto
si tenemos un problema y eliminamos las
causas claro esperamos que el problema
también se elimine
pero lo que no vemos a veces es que
eliminar esas causas puede generar
nuevos problemas o puede empeorar el que
ya estaba como en este caso
entonces
qué creen ustedes realmente deberíamos
ver los problemas desde estos ojos o no
desde esta perspectiva o no
así que volviendo al caso como
resolvimos el enigma
justamente utilizando pensamiento
sistémico para explicarles un poquito
este concepto vamos a hacer un ejercicio
entonces les voy a pasar esta cuerda
la idea es que todos pongan sus dedos de
esta forma y van a pasar la cuerda que
pueda fluir por sus dedos por fermí
vamos a pasarla hacia atrás entonces sí
ya hacia atrás hacia la izquierda
hacia la derecha
atrás
hacia adelante
dejemos ahí entonces la última persona
por favor ten la cuerda muy duro lo que
voy a hacer es jalar esta cuerda
[Risas]
quienes de ustedes sintieron la atención
todo es cierto todos los que tenían la
cuerda sintieron esa tensión
eso es justamente lo que queremos
analizar con pensamiento sistémico en
este momento ustedes son un sistema y
todas las decisiones que tomen ustedes
que tome cualquier persona que tiene la
cuerda en jalarla en atraparla acá los
que la soltaron y se fue la cuerda eso
termina impactando el resultado del
sistema termina impactando las
decisiones de los demás y esto es lo que
hace el pensamiento sistémico
identificar qué personas hacen parte de
ese sistema qué intereses tienen cómo
actúan y cómo esas decisiones terminan
generando cosas que nos gustan y cosas
que no así que lo que hicimos fue formar
un equipo interdisciplinario en el que
había médicos psicólogos trabajadores
sociales y yo la ingeniera y nos fuimos
a trabajar en campo nos fuimos a
entrevistar a las personas que hacían
parte de este sistema a las personas con
tuberculosis los médicos la cps es las
ips es los familiares
y entre estas personas queríamos
entender cuáles eran sus miedos y
expectativas y cómo se relacionaban con
esta enfermedad
uno de ellos fue expedito cañaveral
expedito es un líder comunitario
increíble ama a su comunidad con todo el
corazón los conoce a todos ellos lo
adoran lo invitan a los cumpleaños a los
matrimonios a las primeras comuniones en
fin
y él fue el que nos dio la clave para
resolver este enigma
resulta que muchos de estos vecinos que
han tenido tuberculosis y que habían
dejado el tratamiento tenían dos cosas
en común la primera es que en cabeza de
familia la segunda es que tenían
problemas de nutrición ahí estaba la
clave el enigma
la nutrición era la solución y porque
imagínense que el tratamiento de la para
la tuberculosis
consiste en la ingesta de unas pastillas
de varios medicamentos entre los cuales
se encuentran la isoniazida por ejemplo
estos medicamentos son muy fuertes
entonces cuando una persona los ingiere
con el estómago vacío puede generar
efectos secundarios como vómitos
malestar general que impiden que las
personas sigan con su vida diaria con su
rutina normal
así que si esta es una persona que es
cabeza de familia se tomó la pastilla no
tenía nada en su estómago entonces se
enfermó y no pudo ir a trabajar qué pasa
no tiene con qué alimentar a sus hijos
con que pagar los servicios con que
pagar el arriendo así que decide no
tomarse el tratamiento
así que teniendo esto en cuenta lo que
hicimos fue diseñar unas estrategias
entre ambos programas entre el programa
de nutrición y el programa de
tuberculosis así las personas que
estaban siendo tratadas también era
apoyadas por el programa de nutrición
esto apoyo otros programas otras
estrategias entre programas por ejemplo
con vih y salud mental que estaban
encaminados a fortalecer esa cobertura
en el diagnóstico
adicionalmente expedito aprendió sobre
la tuberculosis él aprendió cuáles eran
los síntomas clave como el tratamiento
cuáles mitos eran verdad cuáles no y
esto lo empezó a transmitir en su
comunidad empezó a apoyar el programa
desde su comunidad
veía una persona tosiendo con todos y le
decía oiga vaya y se hace el examen
sabía que una persona uno de sus vecinos
ya estaba en tratamiento y le preguntaba
todos los días ya se toma el tratamiento
cómo va con el tema cómo se ha sentido
y esta estrategia se extendió a todo el
país miles de líderes comunitarios están
apoyando el programa desde sus
comunidades con su gente en los sistemas
en los cuales ellos hacían parte
adicionalmente expedito también nos
recuerda con esto la responsabilidad que
tenemos todos de transformar nuestros
sistemas de transformar lo que estos
sistemas están produciendo que esto no
es solamente una responsabilidad del
gobierno sino una responsabilidad de
todos también nos lleva a pensar de
pronto que todos estos mecanismos que
llamamos alternativos de resolución de
conflictos y de problemas de oria tal
vez ser los normales y los normales los
alternativos
este es solamente un caso
en el utilizar pensamiento sistémico
para diseñar soluciones diseñar
estrategias
y que lo hace diferente que hace
diferente el pensamiento sistémico y los
mecanismos que utilizamos hoy en día lo
a resumir en tres pasos o en tres cosas
la primera es que considera todas las
personas que hacen parte del sistema en
este caso cómo les decía las personas
con tuberculosis sus familias sus
vecinos los médicos el estado del
gobierno los empleadores las ongs e
incluso los líderes comunitarios
lo segundo es entender esos intereses y
decisiones fíjense que todos tomamos
decisiones para satisfacer nuestros
intereses entonces si ustedes tienen
hambre que hace comen si tienen frío van
por una cobijita por un chocolatito
cierto si en una injusticia denuncia
en este caso un empleador un empleador
subjetivo cuál es lograr la mayor
productividad en su empresa si tiene un
empleado que falta constantemente y eso
está impactando sus resultados
posiblemente cuando se le acaba el
contrato no se lo va a renovar cierto
la persona con tuberculosis obvio obvio
se quiere recuperar
pero si este tratamiento genera que no
pueda ir a trabajar y de su trabajo
depende que sus hijos coman qué decisión
va a tomar pues no se toma el
tratamiento
entender estos intereses es clave así
como la interacción entre las personas
esto hace referencia a la actividad que
hicimos ahorita con la cuerda
en un sistema todas las personas están
relacionadas entre sí
cualquier acción va a causar una
reacción sobre alguien más y va a
producir para producir algo siempre sea
tuberculosis sea justicia sea paz sea
criminalidad para pos va va a producir
cosas distintas entonces una vez
entendemos personas intereses decisiones
y cómo interactúan entre sí ya estamos
en la capacidad de entender ese sistema
y de verdad identificar dónde podemos
impactar
ya cuando sabemos cómo podemos impactar
lo podemos diseñar de esta forma
soluciones reales soluciones de impacto
acá ya no no ya no queremos esa pastilla
que alivia el problema
queremos una solución real
y esto ocurre aquí gracias a que vemos
los problemas de lejos vemos la solución
más de cerca
ustedes consideran justo que estos
sistemas con los cuales interactuamos de
los cuales hacemos parte estén
produciendo hacinamiento enfermedades
criminalidad recuerden que todos
absolutamente todos tenemos la
responsabilidad de transformar estos
sistemas y transformar lo que producen y
tenemos esas las capacidades necesarias
para hacerlo así que ustedes están
dispuestos a hacerlo están dispuestos a
ver los problemas desde otros ojos desde
otras perspectivas para así diseñar
soluciones reales efectivas y diferentes
qué hacer
[Aplausos]